And that brings me to my first major of two tenets of "Half the Sky"...
...and that is that the central, moral challenge of this century is gender inequity.
In the 19th century, it was slavery.
In the 20th century, it was totalitarianism.
The cause of our time is the brutality that so many people face around the world because of their gender.
So, some of you may be thinking, "Gosh, that's hyperbole."
"She's exaggerating."
Well, let me ask you this question.
How many of you think there are more males or more females in the world?
Let me take a poll.
How many of you think there are more males in the world?
Hands up, please.
How many of you think...
A few.
How many of you think there are more females in the world?
Okay, most of you.
Well you know this latter group, you're wrong.
There are, true enough in Europe, in the West,...
...when women and men have equal access to food and health care,...
...there are more women, we live longer.
But in most of the rest of the world, that's not the case.
In fact, demographers have shown that there are anywhere between 60 million and 100 million...
...missing females in the current population.